may remember about two months ago when
Italy had an election and now they have
uh new prime minister Georgia Maloney
and of course she gets in and she's on
the right so everyone says she's a
fascist this is going to bring us back
to World War II she's evil blah blah
blah but if you just listen to her
speeches which they will not show you on
CNN and they're not going to type out
transcripts of in the Washington Post or
the New York Times what she is talking
about is sovereignty Italian sovereignty
she's talking about secure borders she's
talking about caring about her citizens
before this globalist agenda and she
gave a another I mean she's really I
think the star in World politics right
now she gave a absolutely spectacular
speech about globalism and here she's
hitting France in particular when it
comes to these these globalist ideas and
the exploitive hypocrisy of the whole
freaking thing foreign
[Applause]
and the fire at the end her point is in
this case she's talking directly to
France but I think you can export this
idea or you can you can compare this
idea to what's going on with the
globalist you guys create all of these
problems all over the world why do 14
Nations use uh French money right and
then you abuse the people there you know
it's funny when I've done my uh funny
it's I guess depressing to some level
when I've done my Off the Grid August a
couple times we went to Bora Bora it's
in French Polynesia meaning that the
French are basically occupying these
Polynesian Islands and you know what
happens all of the natives all of the
Polynesians that live on these islands
all they they're bet the best job that
you can get is to work at one of these
Resorts now usually the top staff at the
resorts they're all French uh meaning
they're native French people but you can
be a cleaning lady at a resort you can
be a bartender at a resort or a waitress
at a resort and those are the best jobs
you can get in French Polynesian but we
don't talk about occupation or anything
else anyway her point is we in her
context she's talking about the Italians
is I want to protect our borders we
don't need to allow all of these people
in because we feel guilty about the good
civilization we've built how about we
point the finger at the people who are
exploiting the African nations in this
case she's talking about the French